ladies and gentlemen this is not a test
there's a major hurricane that is in the
Gulf of Mexico really over the last half
hour so the worst of the storm has now
reached New Orleans this is the moment
we've been talking about reading I'm
wondering how long these levees are
gonna hold on Lake Pontchartrain the
city absolutely devastated by Katrina
[Music]
I'm told that the Norland fleet put out
a calls walas officers saying if you
have a boat bring it here help us these
are people who not have the wherewithal
to get out of town they didn't have cars
there's no way they could pay for a
hotel room they stayed in their houses
because they had to and then the water
came up this is life and death but I
want people to know there's a lot of
help coming you know maybe help us on
the way the immediate situation is with
each passing hour the situation gets
more dire the government said you go in
that Superdome and you'll get help and
they didn't get help they got locked in
there there was no power
air-conditioning water thousands were
stranded in wretched conditions I want
to thank Senator frist
and Senator Reid for their extraordinary
efforts to listen to politicians
thanking each other and complimenting
each other you know I got to tell you
there are a lot of people here who are
very upset I want everyone in the world
to see six days after Katrina swept
through this city
five days after the levee collapse look
look in the face of the baby
so many of these people almost all of
them that we see are so poor and they
are so black destruction of the spirit
of the people of southern Louisiana and
Mississippi meaning up being the most
tragic loss of all George Bush doesn't
care about black people the aftermath of
Hurricane Katrina will go down as one of
the worst abandonments of Americans on
American saw ever in US history you need
to know that our whole nation cares
about you and in the journey ahead
you're not alone
you